all right i guess christmas came early
because i thought it was going to be
tomorrow
when the marble guys come and put the
marble on
but i guess they're coming here today i
just got a text
that they're outside i'm still in my jiu
jitsu close i literally just got back
from jiu jitsu
today was no ghee day so i don't have my
ghee
but they're outside and i am so freaking
excited i cannot wait look
oh my truck's blocking it but if you
take a look those are two trucks back
there
with the goods
there it is
beautiful oh thank you
it won't fit in there
oh no
oh because of the dolly at the bottom
huh
uh-oh i've never really known him
okay yeah yeah thank goodness hey man
excuse everyone
i thought we were gonna have big trouble
that we couldn't get that in here and
someone's gonna have to take apart the
door but i guess they'll just bring it
in piece by piece those pieces are huge
and heavy so we gotta be real careful
right now everyone
okay go ahead yeah go ahead thank you
yeah so now we gotta move all that stuff
to the side
so no tv for a day or two
and then they're gonna bring a giant
scaffolding into because i have to go
all the way up there which would be sick
hey look at that
damn nice
can you imagine a giant piece like that
over there
i can't even imagine it
the funny thing is i've seen the
renderings in the mock-up
and it looks freaking oh it's right
there it looks super sick
but still nothing beats seeing it in
person you know
because like you could touch it it's
like the natural grain there's texture
oh that is beautiful
look at these edges
everything is cut precisely
because what's gonna happen if like this
is the um
let's say this is the fireplace it's
gonna wrap around too so the edges are
uh diagonal so it can meet perfectly and
have a corner
so it looks like this
that's nice
[Music]
i always forget how big this tv is
is uh it's a 82 inch
yeah it's big this this house is big so
it doesn't look big but then when people
stand next to it you're like oh wow that
thing's pretty big
yeah yeah yeah i'm late on my mountain
all right everything's been moved look
how naked the fireplace is this is what
the fireplace looked like when we first
moved in you guys remember and look how
huge it is
i always forget how tall it is because
i'm not staring at just that i'm
watching tv i'm running around with
tycoon doing nerf wars or whatever
so since it is a huge piece it's going
to be a multi-day job the first day
we're just going to try to get to that
line
so get it to this line and also pass
over here so this bottom part should be
covered which is how we moved everything
over there look how big that tv is i
always forget how big it is
oh one
special secret tip
when i buy electronics to get a good
deal i always wait until the end of the
year right when the new models came in
so i believe i bought this tv in
2020 and i bought the 2019 model so it
was actually two thousand dollars
cheaper because the new ones just came
in so i think the new one was like five
g's this one i got for three g's
relatively the same specs maybe just a
couple things here and there um but i
mean tvs are so good these days you
can't even tell like from like the top
of the line from 2017 to like maybe 2020
you could barely tell you know after you
watch
you're into the eighth season of a show
of like squid games or something you're
so sucked into the story you're not
going to tell in terms of quality so
that's my tip i always buy the top of
the line of last year and you'll get a
really good deal and it lasts a long
time because it's still high technology
but i can't wait for them to bring it in
damn
mama brought home
the yummy what's going on lunch
i know their goal is uh try to bring
the marble up to eye level today and
have that wrapped around and then uh
tomorrow they're gonna bring in a giant
scaffolding
to go all the way up there
i saw you got milkshakes in there who's
are the who's this whose is there two oh
there's only two
or is there
three
i don't know look
use your eyes that's uh
you little better
dude you totally screwed me i know
so these came in i'm like what the hell
is this when do we ever get regular
lemonade because i always get pink
lemonade because the pink lemonade in
and out is freshly squeezed it's
delicious and this is like from
concentrate i mean it's i haven't even
tried it but i just love the in and out
pink lemonade and i texted lemonade not
pink lemonade thinking that 10 years of
history would mean pink lemonade but
beer stuck to it don't say it like that
literally no don't say it like okay
you're a literal person okay so tell me
how should i say it you're the person
that's like i always write what i mean
so i'm like that's true you could sing
all day like man i can't wait to get
lemonade and i always look lemonade too
it's not a arnold palmer
yeah that's true i messed up
so then when i was ordering it i'm like
man people must be honest with me have i
been sleeping on the lemonade i'm like
all right i'll get lemonade too so two i
know i screwed both of those over
but i got the healthy one
that's the healthy one no spread ketchup
and mustard
that's cool
it's kind of sick i have to cut the
little sockets
to make these guys work huh
so what's cool is they got the big job
done like when they did the digital
rendering they measured the fireplace so
they already got that pre-cut
but i guess all these little ones they
had to measure to make sure they get it
right so that we can ultimately mount
our tv which is the goal because this
house has such a beautiful dope
fireplace right here and our old house
we needed that home theater setup but
over here we don't want to cover it up
so
once you get the tv mounted i'm going to
try to figure out the best way
to have the home theater set up
because i don't want to spend any more
money but what was advised of me is
getting like a sound bar and then you
would get all of the like networking and
boxes and all that stuff put in that
networking room over there
but i don't want to have to spend any
more money so if i can if there's a way
i can put all of those home theater
boxes
where we have them and still keep like
these tower speakers
that would be dope but yeah this is a
networking room
that we have so here
is where we run like
our um
where is it oh right here behind here
that's all of our wi-fi of all of our
hard lines
that goes to every single room and then
that's our surveillance system but you
know how some homes they have a crazy
like like stat stack stack stack
then we can get that done depending on
how sophisticated we want to be we don't
want it to be too sophisticated but
as little money as i could spend and
keep these really cool speakers
that would be the goal
babe
you're going to want to see this
[Music]
are you sure about that i'm pretty sure
tycho you want to see something cool
you're going to want to see this
no that's okay close it close it
[Music]
[Music]
whatever looks sick huh oh my god it
looks incredible
oh my goodness
what's going on dude
let's see if they sink or float what is
that a mountain
oh it sinks
what about your poppy let's see
paper what does the paper do
nice
what about that bubble wrap
oh that one floats too
what if we try to sink it does it float
or stays down or stays up
a lot of water in there that's skinny
whoa can make like a dumpster well you
got a good imagination
you can make a lot of stuff
meanwhile we're inside the garage
my bear's training hitting them sets
let's see let's see let's see get after
it everything after it let me see let me
see hit them set
let me see hit them sets right there
let's go we i don't do it your time i
got my time okay what are you warming up
or what are you doing yeah i'm moving up
this is one last moment before my
working stuff all right let me see let
me see you hit them sets then i'm only
doing it by one okay let me see goodbye
one
record okay let me see record
so for those of you guys that don't know
these are bands these are band
attachments
and the school of thought of this is
called accommodating resistance meaning
throughout the range of motion as you're
increasing the range of motion
in the concentric part of the movement
you're adding more resistance
incrementally so it forces you to
accelerate because force equals mass
times acceleration so by adding
resistance on the acceleration part you
are there increasing your force
production and yes i am a fitness guru i
will not admit that very often
and it sometimes impresses myself how
much i know about fitness but going back
to playing dumb on life
good job mama thank you baby are you
gonna be strong
i hope so
but why do people arch their fat part
because they got back problems
oh damn you're playing dumb now
let's go in for what hit them sets let's
go hit them sets baby baby
hit them sets
let's go
boom
nice wow that was like really easy that
was clean yeah hell yeah
thank you
honestly though that i did impress
myself with the amount of knowledge i
have because i mess around so much in
fitness that i forget that i'm super
passionate and really into fitness
what's that
okay good enough talk with you that i
forget that i'm super passionate about
fitness
i actually study read a lot i read a lot
of articles about a lot of phds like
about like from the main authorities in
the space
so i know not a lot of knowledge but
since i don't coach anymore
most of it is just messing around and
when i pretended to know some things i
didn't know some things
so this is where they stopped today
they were able to finish that first
layer
as promised
and i was always wondering what is
securing this marble
to
the wall
besides
just the glue right because i'm like
because that thing could just come like
falling down if the glue ever gives out
or something like that and it's good to
know that they have these like copper
safety wires
and it runs
all the way down
so at least there's like a hanging thing
so if we see it i think come off it'll
like
hang and we'll know uh someone needs to
come in and repair it
but so far looks crazy good look at that
corner
came together really good really nicely
we got that safety there
so
looks freaking sick
look at that
so with this
and then with that new addition we just
need to put glass in it
this whole house is going to look super
modern
steezy and sick once we get the neon
lights in there
it's gonna look like a party house
it's gonna look like a super fun filled
place
probably like a
like a goofier
and cheaper version of steve aoki's
house because his house looks fun too he
has a half pipe in the back you jump off
the the top floor into his pool
um
but yeah it'll be something where it
looks dope but also goofy and fun
because that's what's important
and
ma bear took geo what the hell is the
same person um jio took taika to jiu
jitsu
while i was staying back so that i
didn't go talk to
the workers and stuff
all right so mama picked me up after
taika finished jiu jitsu we're still in
the suburb part of vegas where we live
but it seems like a popping area there's
all these
big plazas restaurants and all that and
we're gonna eat here
this is where we
took uh jio's mom for her birthday last
year it's really good it's like a
seafood spot but there's also fleming's
which is a steakhouse and down there
there's like a italian grill
caraba which is really cool and just up
and down the street like there's a
target down there there was a whole
foods of dicks like a bunch of like big
national retailers so it's super cool
kind of reminds me of like um
kind of like glendale galleria if you're
never been in la
or um
any of those big plazas that have like
not just the regular chains like chili's
or tgi but like the nicer chains like
cheesecake factory and stuff like that
and it's just it feels good to see that
there's like
it's popping down here even off the
strip
oh that's warm
that's cozy
you're ridiculous dude
no
be careful you're going to get squished
by the door if you press it too soon
ready go press it and leave press
good
so one of the things that caught my eye
about this place is you guys know how
much i like to grill and barbecue at
home right well look at how they cook
their seafood
wood
fire grill
our selections are slightly seasoned
wood grilled and served with choice of
two signature sides you get scallops
trout mahi mahi chili and seafood oh
what they even have the calories
hell yeah you know i'm trying to be all
health conscious
so
mama show me all your new battle scars
oh man
did you see my legs they're like 10
times worse but these are my arms
oh we got some oh you got more now yeah
i don't think we'll need the second one
though i think this is going to be like
so much bread we're not going to eat
food no you're all good
okay thank you
that was a lot of bread
um
so here are you showing off your biceps
no do you want my bruises or not i do
dude
is there any over here do i have any
down here nope
uh well there's one here oh that's a big
fat i don't even know how this happens a
big one
there's one here
whoa i see it
here
oh my god here the top of my foot i have
a ton here that's not your foot babe no
i'm just saying i have like this just
reminded me of the top of my foot
i actually um tape all my knuckles so
that
so this actually kind of actually feels
really good
oh here look
yeah the crazy grips people get on you
or that i get on you yeah maybe you're
not going to tell people the truth that
i've been beating you up right yeah
everyone knows that's not possible
i mean it is possible but
whatever um
here how do you feel like getting all
these bruises from from jet's class you
feel proud of them you earned them
you earned these bad boys am i proud of
it
i guess so because i was someone that
was like very afraid of contact sports
it was claustrophobic now you're getting
obliterated every day hates all of that
um and i'm having such a good time
that's awesome i'm so proud of you mama
thank you and i'm learning how to defend
myself the whole time not only defend
yourself but also defend this dude yeah
and you and me too
so proud of you mama
thank you papa
damn look at that got scallops
shrimp asparagus
hey mama got the chili and sea bass
with the lemon butter
i'm gonna do it without the lemon butter
this alone tastes really good a little
bit of salt and pepper
that looks nice nice little fillet
action right there
a lot of cracked pepper oh yeah baby
yeah delicious you want some of this
nah i'm gonna try to eat
one of these scallops right here
look at that
oh it's all drippy with sauce
a little bit of lemon
butter right there
[Music]
yummy
very juicy
very good